they thought they were prepared at Oak
Springs care home in Liverpool it made
no difference 16 of their residents have
died making it one of the hardest hit in
the country and only two were tested and
only when taken to hospital this is the
worst 16 residents is like losing 16
grandparents in such a short space of
time you spend so much time every day
with residents more than you do with 8
residents still isolated they remain
worried and say the government left them
to fend for themselves the information
from other countries the information on
how it affected their homes but failed
to prepare our homes but we wasn't
prepared for was that a GP is not going
to come out that that residents not
going to protect and Hospital that
you're going to be given a course of
antibiotics and a prescription of
paracetamol the new oxygen is going to
be delivered should that residents
become breathless the staff filmed these
pictures for us putting on protective
outfits which are inferior to those in
hospitals and in this Holmes case
they've been dealing with numbers
equivalent to several hospital wards at
one stage more than half the star for
off work with no access to tests they
don't recognize the health Secretary's
claims from the staff we've been testing
people in care homes as I said there's
more than 10,000 of those tests that
have been done throughout and we know
that 85% of our care homes do not have
an outbreak of kovat 19 but Sky News has
spoken to three of the UK's largest care
home providers with hundreds of homes
between them and found around 60% have
coronavirus cases if that's replicated
in thousands of others the infection
rate is far higher than
mitad and in oak springs the testing
claims are far too late three weeks down
the lines Nino and snow God I had to
take home at micro home
my residents less than 50% of my staff
because the government didn't have their
action plan embedded to be to be action
straight away and more than 30 MPs have
written to the health secretary taking
issue with his planes of testing in the
care home sector well certainly the
assertion made by mus Hancock and indeed
the chief medical officer is not
substantiated by the evidence that me
and my team have collected we found all
care homes in my constituency and there
has been no testing whatsoever even in
those care homes where there has been
signs of coded 90 the government says
the lockdown has slowed community
infections but the scientists admit it's
still spreading in care homes it means
in the community it's likely that the
virus and the epidemic is now shrinking
there are areas such as hospitals and
social care settings where there may be
growth in some places the staff at Oak
Springs have been called astonishingly
courageous they all agree testing and an
earlier government lockdown of care
homes would have made a critical
difference people knew this was common
before it came how many people on us and
I think it could have been prevented and
lives could have been saved that's nice
they've described it as the worst three
weeks ever abandoned they say to cope
with the deadly virus on their own Alex
Crawford Sky News Liverpool